10h10 on s'intéresse au fondateur de
l'hôtel dieu de beaune nicolas rolin qui
a justement un rapport aussi avec
auteuil marie thérèse gars il est né en
1376 out 1 et donc c'est le fondateur de
l'hôtel dieu c'est lui c'est grâce à lui
que l'on doit cette célèbre vente des
vins des hospices faits qui datent à 2,7
et la 158e vente des vins mais si on
n'avait pas eu l'hôtel du à beaune on
n'aurait pas eu la vente des vins ce
week-end passé alors nicolas rolin va
partir faire des études en avignon à
l'université d'avignon il va la faculté
de droit
c'est un homme qui a une grande ambition
mais aussi très intelligent
beaucoup de charisme très bon orateur et
très vite nicolas rolin deviendra un
éminent juriste il va donc travailler
pour le compte du duc de bourgogne jean
sans peur et quand celui ci sera
assassiné son fils philippe lebon donc
notre nouveau duc va le prendre comme
non seulement conseillé mais elle va le
faire
chancelier nicolas rolland qui s'est
marié trois fois
alors nicolas roelens marie trois fois
une première fois avec une beaunoise
elmer une deuxième fois avec la fille
d'un riche banquier de gênes aylmer et
enfin il pense qu'il peut encore se
marier une troisième fois
jamais 2 sans 3 me révéla et là ça sera
le coup de foudre le vrai coup de feu ah
oui oui je pense parce que quand on voit
la devise qu'il va dédier à guigone de
salins est l'étoile la seule étoile de
sa vie c'est vraiment le coup de foudre
alors lui il a 47 ans l élan à 20 il
faut dire que nicolas rolin et le
chancelier donc c'est aussi c'est le le
ministre de la justice d'ailleurs quand
on parle de chancellerie c'est bien ça
vient de chancelier et il va se marier
avec guigone de salins qui est la fille
détiennent de salins qui lui est
chambellan leur chambellan c'est-à-dire
un intendant n'attendant d'un droit d'un
prince d'un noble et il connaît chez
nicolas rolin le père de guy gones de
salingue connais bien nicolas rolin et
quand ils vont se rencontrer
et bien très vite ce sera le mariage à
lons le saunier et très vite ils ont les
mêmes idées à leur guidon de salins est
une femme très généreuse quand nous
faire paraître pardon d'une trop grande
douceur qui s'intéresse à tous elle
s'intéresse non seulement à l'eau
mathématiques à la rhétorique à la elle
parle latin falx fait du latin et elle
se passionne avec son père etienne de
salins à l'astrologie
elle fait de l'équitation la chasse au
faucon et ça sera vraiment le grand
amour de nicolas rolin très bien les
montées inépuisable pour fait l'icône de
cette voie là ça sera ça sa conscience
sont son double spirituel et quand
nicolas rolin décide donc c'est à l'âge
de 67 ans qu'ils demandent au pape la
construction d'un hôpital pour les
pauvres et pour les pauvres il veut un
palais alors dans le sens de palets sait
recevoir des malades comme des princes
et au départ c'est pas beau une qu'elle
choisit au départ c'est chalon sur saône
puis autant sa ville natale
et finalement il va faire le bon choix
bonin c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
en rhône alpes une belle image merci
nicolas reul à je reprécise que samedi à
11h30 et sur vos écrans connectés
vous allez retrouver le meilleur de la
vente des vins des hospices de beaune
ça risque d'être très grand moment je
suis laissé dire que nathalie baye nous
a accordé quelques minutes les manuels
béart aussi et nicolas rolin on pourrait
faire un parcours entre la bourgogne et
la franche comté sur les pas de nicolas
rolin parce que il a des résidences un
peu partout jusque dans le nord de la
bourgogne sert les flandres et on
pourrait aller de de châtillon-sur-seine
à héricourt en haute saône comme en
passant par
l'isle sur le doubs à beaune bien sûr à
dijon à autun on pourrait faire tout un
parcours sur les pas de nicolas rolin à
travers la bourgogne et la franche comté
on le voit à borner vers nantes wallon
desaulniers haute une salle un besoin
sont évidemment la roche sur l'ognon
reliques os x était malade et résidences
un peu partout jusque dans le nord de la
bourgogne donc les flancs d'un
personnage très important là un
personnage très important qu'on retrouve
sur de nombreuses plaques de rues et
voilà à place donc convenu franchement
voilà l'explication de ce personnage
célèbre exactement plaque de rue quai
nicolas-rolin dijon